I want to close with some general comments about the uses of models and simulation.
All simulation of Apollo 13 is just one example of what can be done with these techniques
from mathematics and computer science.
These techniques allow us to do experiments that can't be done in real life.
They may be too expensive in real life.
For instance, building 1000 cars to find the right aerodynamic shape.
They may be too dangerous.
For instance, if we ask the astronauts to actually try out different boost
or they may be outright impossible--for instance, we want to look at the universe
that has different fundamental constants of nature.
We may use simulations for simple prediction, for optimization, to study causes and effects
for instance of earthquakes or climate change,
and we may use models and simulation to determine unobservable quantities
such as the composition of the interior of the earth.